[Music]
Bachelorette frontrunner Garrett
apologizes for liking hurtful and
offensive Instagram posts you know
people say and do certain things I've
done things in the past that I'm sure I
it wasn't the best thing but I just want
people to stay open-minded to everyone
earlier this week the 29 year old Nevada
native deleted his account after
screenshots went viral of Garrett liking
images that mocked transgender people
feminists immigrants and parkland
shooting survivors
shortly after Garrett created a new
account to start fresh he posted this
lengthy apology quote I am sorry to
those who I offended and I also take
full responsibility I have learned an
extremely valuable lesson and I'm taking
steps to grow become more educated and
be a better version of myself
Garrett also insists the liked photos
were not a true reflection of who he is
nor his morals quote I do not want my
social media to define who I am and I
will take better care moving forward to
support all walks of life et sat down
with Bachelorette Becka kufran on
Wednesday where she addressed the
controversy I can't fault anyone for
what they believe and who's to say that
anything that anyone likes is truly what
they believe and if they just DoubleTap
I can't speak to that because it's not
me but I am a strong woman and I do
believe in certain things but again
that's what's so great about our country
is everyone is entitled to their own
opinions how would you address something
like that with any guy really if you
found out something like that we would
have a discussion about it we would get
to the bottom of it and find the
solution
you